[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tim kirchen espn baseball reporter tim
how do i look today
you look better than i do aaron boone
told me not long ago that i look like dr
fauci
he's 80. you look like dr fauci he's 80.
and then the other day
when i was in boston for the wild card
game i ran into some friends and the
wife of who i know very well but i
haven't seen her in years she said
you know now that paul giamatti's lost a
lot of weight and you've gotten a lot
older you look like paul giamatti
that i don't know if that's a compliment
or not i don't look like paul giamatti
all i know is you look better than i do
and we are of similar age thank you tim
i feel a lot better that's the only
reason why i wanted you to come on to
say something nice about me so thank you
very much i i mentioned this uh last
hour and my guys did not they whipped on
it they didn't get the answer
i'm gonna guess that you'll know this i
have a favorite pitcher he's still in
the playoffs he's had a lot of success
in the playoffs and he's 37 years of age
do you want to guess the pitcher that i
i love he's a guy that i love watching
pitch
all right it's charlie morton yes it is
i love charlie
dan he's better now than he was when he
was 27. he's better now than he was when
he was 31. this is the beauty of
baseball you know this the light goes on
for certain guys i told you once that
matt diaz like 12 years ago in the
braves clubhouse i mean the pirates
clubhouse in spring training told me
pointed to charlie morton and said roy
halliday and i'm looking at charlie
morton's numbers and said he can't beat
roy holliday and matt dyer said watch
it's going to come for this guy and it
has and now he's 37 years old he's got
as good of curveball as there is in the
major leagues he throws 98 miles an hour
yesterday 37 on short rest he by the way
he is a he's a
expert barbecue guy he can make
furniture he can play the guitar he can
sing he can do all this stuff and yet he
i think he wants to retire but he's way
too good to retire they keep bringing
them back and he's he's so good he says
all right i'll play for another year
because i'm good i know and he's and you
know success in the postseason it's just
he's one of those guys that you get to
the postseason you see him pitch and you
go i'll be damned you know he's on a
different team but he's still very
successful um right and he's so good by
the way dan with barbecue sorry to
interrupt he he has a little hitch on
the back of his car
where his truck where he can take
the grill with him wherever he goes so
he's going to get so i said if you ever
this when he was with the raise i said
have you ever taken the grill like to
the ballpark he said no way you have to
start grilling and and all that at you
know three o'clock in the morning i'm
not going to the trap at three o'clock
in the morning just to feed my my
teammates so he's really good at stuff
like that i brought up jose altuve who
once again had a really good postseason
or he started out there and then i i was
wondering
that let's say they get to the world
series let's say they face the dodgers
the cheating you know scandal is going
to come up again from 2017.
are the voters going to hold that
against jose altuve for the hall of fame
i think some will um i've been a voter
for
31 years and
i'm not gonna hold it against him he's
gonna have hall of fame numbers for sure
just go look at where he is in his
career now look at how many hits he's
got he's got 19 postseason homers he's
stolen bases he's won gold gloves he won
an mvp and i understand he was in the
middle of something he shouldn't have
been in the middle of
but i'm not so naive to think that yeah
they're the only team that ever tried to
steal a sign or cheat or something like
that we've been doing this in baseball
for 140 years and i'm not condoning any
of it but if you're asking me would i
vote for him
if he has the numbers i will do i think
some people will say no he was part of
something he should have been a part of
him not vote for him yes i think that
will happen to some degree
yeah and
you know i i get usually a flood of
emails whenever the astros do well
because they're like see we don't need
to cheat uh we're good and i always say
but why did you cheat in the first place
if you didn't need to cheat are they a
great story this year if they go to the
world series yes that's a great story it
doesn't take away 2017. i still think
baseball baseball had taken away
physically taking away the world series
trophy since you couldn't take away
anything else except for a couple of
jobs with manager and gm
would would we be satisfied with that as
uh you know the baseball jury
um i don't think that's a good idea
because if you take it away dan now
other teams are going to say well what
about us we lost the world series i'm
just making this up in 1989
because the whole team we played against
was juiced and then the 51 dodgers can
say well the giants were stealing signs
and they beat us in two out of three and
ended up going to the world series why
don't we win the national league pennant
i just don't think you can open up
that box because there are too many
things in it dan look for the rest of
time all those guys are going to have
that as part of their resume some of
them are going to have it in the first
paragraph of whatever big story is
written about them and they're gonna get
booed for a long time dan you don't want
people in your industry saying
dan patrick's a cheater he we don't have
any respect for him that may not be
enough punishment you're not taking away
the stats or the money or the trophy but
i sure wouldn't want somebody who i play
against all the time saying i have no
respect for you for what you did that
would hurt
that would really hurt me i know that
you want the astros dodgers
well i i think that would be pretty good
um
but let's just say the giants who were
supposed to win 74 games this year were
supposed to win fewer games than the
diamondbacks we lost like 200 games this
year
and the red sox who finished last last
year let's say the red sox played the
giants in the world series i mean that
would be wildly interesting but yes i
think everyone thinks that la against
houston would be really cool a rematch
and all that stuff i'm just a little
afraid dan i'm sorry i'm way too much of
a
of a goody two-shoes here that we would
get away from how great these players
are and these teams are and concentrate
more on what happened four years ago and
i'm just not sure that's what we should
be doing in 2021 all right set the scene
for thursday night dodgers giants
well
the giants are so good dan and i'm
telling you i've looked for a comparable
and i can't find it of a team that was
supposed to win 74 games and didn't add
anybody of great significance where you
can point to them and say well that's
the reason they're so much better the 45
red sox won 71 games and the next year
they won 104 and beat the yankees and
went to the world series but ted
williams came back from world war ii and
hit 342. that's the reason they got so
much better you can't identify that with
the giants which is what makes their
story so fascinating now they have good
players i mean buster posey's a
borderline hall of famer chris bryant
these guys are good players but the
whole team bought into this team concept
they hit the ball out of the ballpark
they pitch really well and the scene for
for tomorrow night is going to be
spectacular in that ballpark two teams
who've never played in the playoffs of
you know since 1900 playing in a winner
take all game and dan at the moment they
both have 109 wins 109
and they're playing a best of five and
get and the deciders tomorrow night i
can't wait i just wonder if uh there's
any similarities with the oral
herscheiser dodgers when they won the
world series when
they didn't have star power they had
oral um
but it wasn't a lineup that was a
murderous row in fact you know didn't
bob costas famously come out and say
something prior to the start of that
series about you know you you're going
against a great team like the oakland
a's and the dodgers really have no
chance i'm paraphrasing bob here but you
know that that wasn't a formidable
lineup that they had
right but the giants lineup is foreign
they were leading the national league in
home runs for most of the season and
they think they finished second just a
couple behind so they have a very good
lineup they just do it in a slightly
different way instead of having three
hall of famers we're gonna hit 40 homers
in the middle everyone on the team has
hit five or more homers like 10 guys hit
10 or more homers and from one through
eight in the order and the order always
changes somebody can hit the ball out of
the ballpark lamont wade wilmer flores
all these guys who are are decent
players but when you put them in the
right matchup they become a really good
player for that day that's the secret of
the giants talking to tim kirchen
baseball reporter and uh he'll be with
carl ravage part of espn's regular
baseball tonight telecast through the
remainder of the postseason shows uh the
show airs every night at midnight
eastern espn radio also the national
audio home of the postseason continuing
that coverage all the way through the
world series
what's best for uh baseball with shohei
ohtani his
future well he's got to keep doing what
he's doing and that's going to be really
hard to do to pitch that well
for me but where do you it is oh oh i
see um
he should play with the angels
mike trout and he should be
the stars that we all want to see
and i don't think it's that far off but
they are going to have to add literally
three
quality starting pitchers if this is
gonna happen and then they're gonna have
to add two quality relievers if this is
gonna happen and they can do that i
believe with the money they have i mean
just imagine dan
mike trout's the best player most of us
have ever seen i saw willie mays play so
mike trout might be the second best
player i've ever seen but shohei ohtani
is no one's ever seen that guy before
imagine those two guys the best player
you've ever seen and the most remarkable
player you've ever seen taken their team
into the playoffs i think you have to
keep those two together and then do
whatever it takes to build around them
i'm not sure you can do it but i just
don't think they're that far off from
being a playoff team baseball is a funny
game you go from real bad to real good
real good to real bad all of a sudden i
think it can happen with the angels but
they better get some pitching soon
but i just wonder how how long do you
keep ohtani with the dual duties there
with pitching and and being in the
everyday lineup
well as long as you possibly can because
his stuff is tremendous that split dan
is unhittable
his offense obviously is his power is
ridiculous he hit eight triples no one's
ever
done what he did last year when it comes
to pitching defense and mostly speed and
power it's just so i would tell him if
you're up for it physically we want you
to do exactly what you did in 2021 and
if he can do that again don't stop i
just wonder if he'll be sort of a
baseball version of bo jackson where bo
played football played baseball
probably could have been a hall of famer
if he committed to one sport i wonder if
ohtani
could he be a hall of famer at both
positions if he concentrated on just one
of those positions
uh i think he would have a chance and
look i love bo jackson i could tell you
hours of bo jackson's story some of the
things i saw him do but ohtani's a
better hitter than bo jackson was and
obviously
he's a better pitcher than bojacks was
and yes if botany said i just want to
hit i think he could hit a ton of homers
steal a ton of bases and be a way above
average defensive outfielder i think if
he just wanted a pitch i think he could
be a 20 game winner with an era under
three that's how good i think he is bo
jackson by the way dan
was the fastest and the strongest guy in
the game i believe at the same time
think about that he could outrun anyone
and he was stronger than anyone
jimmy stewart a scout once told me a
long time ago he said i scouted bo in
college he said i saw him hit a 500 foot
home run and then he ran out and caught
it before it hit the ground and then he
threw it back the whole plate in the air
that's how he described the tools of
bojack
not that it happened but you know
[Music]
he was joking yeah it's still he's one
of those
he's just one of those names that if he
had stayed healthy you just wonder what
he would have accomplished in in either
one of those sports
yeah uh george brett used to tell me he
said i never never once missed a bo
jackson at bat i never went to the
bathroom once during a bojacks in a bat
because i might miss something
that i've never seen before and i was
there that night dan you know that when
he ran up the right the left center
field fence in baltimore i was covered
in that game he looked like a race car
going around a ramp turn you know a 240
pound man at full speed running up the
fence like that it was fascinating and
every time harold reynolds used to tell
me we love harold reynolds of course
every time bo would get on first in like
a double play situation harold would
yell to him oh this is baseball
because harold was gonna have to hang in
there at second base if he was turning
two or beau was stealing
right we don't have to do that anymore
dan but back then when 240 pounds of
metal spikes came at you at 100 miles an
hour that was a bad situation all right
how does the postseason end how does it
play out
um well i've been wrong so far so badly
but i picked the dodgers to beat the
rays in the world series so i'm going to
say
stay with it somehow some way the
dodgers are going to win game five
that's taking nothing away from the
giants and giants i just told you are
great
i just think whoever wins that series
beats the braves even though i just did
the brave series for four games and
freddy freeman is is so good and their
pitching was so great they dominated the
brewers with their pitching i just don't
think the braves can beat the giants or
the dodgers american league i think the
astros beat the the red sox but if you
discount the red sox one more time
you're making a mistake i just think the
astros are better and i think the
dodgers beat the astros in the world
series now that's what i think but i
certainly don't know and the beauty of
this postseason like everyone is anyone
who thinks he knows is going to happen
is just hasn't been watching baseball
for the last 40 years
you're looking good tim
dr fauci and i look an awful lot alike
yeah he's eating i i was talking to a
guy recently we're going over some old
some old baseball from the 50s or 60s
this was a few years ago and he goes oh
you know a lot about baseball what are
you 70 75 i was 58 years old he thought
i was 75.
it who's terrible
keep your head up tim
i will thank you bud
all right see you soon that's tim
kirchen espn baseball reporter